I'm alive when i drive inside i arrived
you got minutes of five then you're on
your own to survive I drive this track
with a scorpion on my back I got my
leather gloves and when push comes to
shove what is it that I can find that I
can fight to love alive on the outside
empty on the inside let's go for a ride
on this road side as the music and
emotions do collide I'm a werewolf
coming up empty I'm a werewolf coming up
slowly I take my time as I take my
strides I do commit crimes but I lack in
pride pull out the driveway speed on
this highway I'm calm and focused on
this getaway what is it that I feel what
is it that i conceal it's interesting
what this music does reveal next-door
neighbor with an adorable kid let's ride
the elevator a smile no longer hid what
is it that I feel what is it i conceal
as music and you reveal and appeal the
foundation of love that is so so real
I'm living in a dream with love and
violence as my theme but you belong to
another no matter this heart flutter no
matter my Chancellor you belong to a
gangster I held your hand and I'll be
goddamned that you're bleeding husband
will cause me to take a stand you know
how I feel this is hard you do steal so
I'll take the hand wheel and help with
this deal so your man went along but the
deal went wrong and no more pop song but
I must remain strong to right this wrong
redhead [ __ ] it's time for you to
twitch and snitch before we ditch shot
gun to your head a bullet you deserve
blood and guts in your all now dead now
you're really on my nerves I'm a dark
stranger you can call me the driver
approaching in anger wielding and
crunching this mother [ __ ] hammer
smash your hand watch it expand now
you're welcome to my wasteland remember
this bullet you put it in a child's
grasp I ought to crack you bend it
before you can grasp blond hair beauty I
apologize for the lies blonde hair
beauty I apologize for your prize
I pull you in I feel your skin feel your
kiss as I touch your lips I may be
cryptic but you are angelic you gave me
something that I never had you turned a
man good who is technically bad evil man
you come to my home silly man you're
walking in the werewolf's zone throw you
to the floor time to get my foot sore I
smash with my heel do you feel what I
feel a Smasher face in and I smash it
add in blood on my shin and blood on my
skin and then I make sure that your life
does end blonde haired beauty you see my
real side blonde hair beauty please
don't hide you kill my best friend now I
kill you too no room to amend I'm coming
for the Jew want to be Italian while i
drive faster than a stallion come on
stuntman let's put on the mask man watch
you shift and drift as I Drive you off
the cliff run all you want I'm walking
towards you run all you want I'm
drowning you the mob boss wishes to
negotiate he must think i have and out
of mine state he wants to take my queen
and declare checkmate I'll bring your
blood money I'll bring your funny money
but don't expect to collect this bounty
because I'm crafting crazy in your
actions are costly but I'm darkly and
deadly I may be smiley but remember I'm
a werewolf that's hungry stab me once
you got a lucky shot I'll stab you once
looks like I hit the deadly spot I love
my angel I regret this gamble but it's
finally final goodbye my queen as I
Drive into the night goodbye my queen
you'll forever be in my sight